Tom Penn NBA TV analyst and a former
Blazers vice president of basketball
operations NBA TV will feature over 30
hours of live free agency focused
programming starting tomorrow 11:00 live
hours on Sunday and Monday and Tom kind
enough to join us Tom thanks for joining
us let me start with this of how many
deals do you think a big deals are
already done that these players and
teams know exactly what's going to
happen I think all of them are pretty
close to done you know the rule is
you're not supposed to talk until that
deadline kicks in but the unwritten rule
is if you ain't cheating you ain't
trying so I think everybody's out there
talking although dan I will say that I
feel like some of the top free agents
Durant Kawhi I don't think they've made
their decision I think those deals are
done and I think they're both looking
forward to the moment of their true
unrestricted free agency where they can
just take their meetings listen to the
plan see what other moves get made to
make that plan a reality and then they'd
make their decision based off of that
who do you think's the first domino in
free agency I think clay Thompson stays
we would all agree with that
I think the big question is and I think
Kawhi comes to LA I believe he comes to
the Clippers
although Vegas has been going back to
Toronto which they usually no and so I
think the biggest domino is sort of the
Durant and the way things shake out I
think if Durant goes on the move
somebody goes with him significant and
then it starts waterfalling after that I
think Kyrie is on the move likely to one
of the New York teams you know so we'll
see I it isn't clear which is what makes
it fun if you had the money and if you
had the cap space would you take on
Kevin Durant
I would yeah I think with his style of
play and with his level of skill and
everything we've heard you know it's not
like an explosive athletic has to get
his offense that way I think for the
next five years after he recovers he's
got plenty of game left in him he's got
plenty of scoring left in him and he's
such a unique talent I would yeah I
bring him I need to bring him back or go
after him
would you want if I if you're the Lakers
and I could give you Kyrie DeAngelo
Russell or Kemba Walker
I'd say neither I'd rather I'd rather
sprinkle that money across multiple
players whether that's two or three or
or whatever else that's going to give
more of a chance of a true team there I
don't think they need another star like
that and I don't think they have the
money to get it done anyway
so when you think back to what Pat Riley
did in Miami the big key there was that
Dwyane Wade took less yeah to begin with
and then LeBron and Bosh followed him
that gave him an extra 15 million bucks
to play with for the next three guys
that doesn't happen here LeBrons got his
max every Davis has his max and it's
just sort of a scenario where you're not
going to get somebody to come in at a
discount so I think they need to shop
for quality free agents and then build
this thing over the course of the year
why don't free agents want to play for
the Knicks it's just such a mess I mean
and it's actually gotten Messier when
you look at their roster the cupboard is
bare I mean they have what do they have
to be excited about other than the idea
of RJ Barrett right and unproven rookie
every better in the world knows that
could go either way and it's just such a
mess from the top from Jim Jim Dolan you
know everybody knows it's just he got
fined again for freezing the media out
to speak all that stuff matters to these
guys
and you know you have to be a unique
person who wants the spotlight
regardless of how brightly it burns and
that's the other thing there if it's not
going well
you're in that spotlight but that thing
burns so I don't know it's just such an
unappealing situation with the revolving
door with coaches with players and their
inability to sustain any sort of plan
there's a report that the Rockets are
interested perhaps in a sign and trade
with Jimmy Butler
I can't imagine Jimmy Butler going into
that situation and making that situation
better I that does his style
first of all does his style fit with
what the Rockets or who the Rockets are
and what do you give up and his sign and
trade for Jimmy Butler yeah it's
complicated
to his style you know I think Mike
D'Antoni's such a gifted offensive coach
that he just likes talent so if you get
him any kind of talent he unleashes
whatever it is offensively and gets the
most out of them you know to your point
and what do they give up since there
have so much money committed to Chris
Paul and James Harden and so on you know
they're over the cap this is have to be
a near dollar-for-dollar swing so you
either have to stack up about 14 players
to get there or you throw Chris Paul in
it I think it's most interesting if
Chris Paul goes out because it's
well-known he wants to move and I you
know the big problem there I feel is the
fact that there's only one ball to go
around and James Harden just dominates
it so much that if you had somehow could
pull it off and he had Chris Paul with
James Harden with Jimmy Butler and Jimmy
Butler isn't exactly a go along quietly
with the team program kind of guy you
know he's grouchy on his best day so I
don't know that was curious to me
well if and you can't you can't ship
Chris Paul to Philadelphia because Phil
why would Philadelphia want Chris Paul
right particularly with his salary of
contracting wherever Chris Paul goes
Chris Paul is going to want to go there
you don't bring a Crabby Chris Paul into
the locker
because he just be a load that you know
it's a real trick bag for them likely
they just come back with what they have
and some incremental improvements or
changes but you never know that that's
this whole thing with the velocity of
movement the more players start moving
the more you'll see big moves because
there are slots for them to go you can
do multi team deals and Dan I don't ever
remember a year where the East and the
West are both so wide open yeah
you know with no clear favorite in
either case so you've got every team
incentivized to effectively go for it
and do it for next year so that that is
exciting in terms of you're going to
have the intention with the opportunity
and let's see what shakes out can Melo
play anymore I don't think so
I mean if you can't play with Mike
D'Antoni and what I just described it's
going to be tricky anywhere else
yeah I'm right there with you on that I
thought you the Rockets are perfect for
him and then I thought the Lakers need
shooters and he couldn't you know he
couldn't stick with one and the other
team wasn't interested in him and he's
he's 35 but I don't know if he's
considered an old 35 but I mean he went
downhill quickly yeah I think he's an
old 35 now that being said game is a lot
easier around that LeBron James
character you know and it's a low-risk
proposition the Lakers only have like
four or five players under contract
three of which you know so there's
plenty of opportunity there and he'd be
a minimum guy and they're going to have
a lot of these minimum ring chasers they
should get the best of the best the way
the Warriors have in past years they
should get the David West type players
that are looking to come in chase a ring
because all the players know if you're
with LeBron you got a great shot and
they have playing time to offer which is
the other thing all these guys want so I
think over the course of the season
you'll see if the trade deadline they
may get
somebody and all these buyouts occur and
veterans are available they'll go there
on a minimum just to play around in LA
and chase a ring got a wild prediction
do I yeah ah what qualifies is wild
I think I'm curious to see what happens
in Philadelphia you know they're pretty
exposed there with Jimmy Butler and with
Tobias Harris and Redick Redick yeah
those guys all three and with the frenzy
that's going to happen you know that
once the dot once the players go they're
gone and there's no ability to replace
and it happens fast
so as built as Philadelphia has been you
know a sort of a perennial contender
they have a lot of work to do in this
next week to ensure that there's they
just keep what they got would you trade
Ben Simmons you know that's interesting
I've my question is whether how great is
he in terms of what they're trying to
accomplish because the clock's ticking
and those extensions now come and then
you just locked into it clear and beet
is a player a-plus you know you build
around him
Simmons is so special but if he's not in
the gym right now working on the his
jump shot I might trade him because he
gotta figure that out you know that just
gets exposed through a playoff or of you
know championship run whose jumpers more
fixable though Tom we're talking to Tom
Penn from NBA TV former Portland
Trailblazers vice president of
basketball operations
Lonzo ball or Ben Simmons look at the
rim I remember his first summer league
and I was intrigued because it had a
bunch of attempts and I always thought
takes we're as good as makes for him
just just get confident get used to
shooting miss who cares
but he hasn't evolved in that way he's
so gifted with the ball with his size
gets to the rim Lonzo has proven in
spurts and has made big shots and he's
certainly willing to take them and I
think that's more fixable
I wouldn't want to do I wouldn't want
have to fix either who wins more games
as crazy as this may sound New Orleans
or the Lakers next season Lakers not
even close
I like its close I mean you got it
remember just how special LeBron is and
Anthony Davis I mean these are two top
five players in the league so that's a
massive move I don't think they're going
to be instant champions necessarily they
could still win the West but they're if
they stay healthy LeBron stays healthy I
mean he can do it himself
yeah I'm not sure not at that age I
don't I don't know Tom I this the first
time I probably had doubts about him and
his greatness first time he missed the
finals and like yeah I know but he he
feels it feels like this load management
is is you know the next big issue for
the commissioner and you know these if
I'm these guys and I look at what Kawhi
did I'm gonna go you know what let's
just get to the playoffs and be rested
so maybe I play 65 games and I chill for
17 do you see this is a growing trend
for these players over the age of 30 32
[Laughter]
we all need load management I got to put
that my next contract hey great to check
in with you too
tom and you know we we appreciate your
time have fun with NBA TV with the free
agency period
all right that's a Tom Penn NBA TV the
former Blazers VP of basketball
operations for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]